this is a production of Cornell
University first of all thanks to dr.
ray Cao and his wife for hosting us
while we're here in Ithaca thanks to
Cornell for having me back I think I was
here about a year and a half ago and
it's it's great to be back um so a
little bit myself I'm gonna speak a
little quickly just because I know I
have about 40 minutes and when I get to
about 30 minutes I'll go even faster
than I thought so they'll let me know
when I get close to that one but I'm a
pediatrician normally I practice five
days a week I'm actually traveling the
world for one year on a research year
with my wife Bella and my child kai here
sitting in the front row over here as
well so I've made the title of this talk
a bit broader than I usually do sort of
you know that the ties you know the ties
between nature and human health and sort
of reconnecting us back with nature
we've lived in natural settings for
thousands of years and evolved in
natural settings it's only really been
in a very recent history that we are now
spending about 90% of our time indoors
that's the average the average American
anyway my disclosures I think taun
already made for me dr. Reich how did
I'm the medical director for Parker X
America and there's no other commercial
affiliations as of yet learning
objectives are pretty straightforward I
want to talk about epidemics I also want
to talk about the epidemic in the
context of climate change natural
resources and this continuing trend
towards urbanization then I want to dive
in as fast as I can to the scientific
literature there's a lot out there
there's more than 500 published studies
scientific studies that have looked at a
connection between nature and human
health and then very quickly just give
you a little glimpse as to what kinds of
things are happening in the world of
applications so how can we take this
science and actually put it to some sort
of applied daily routines you hear about
climate change all the time not going to
spend a lot of time on this but just a
couple of graphics to remind us about
the the sort of you know do
they would hear about on a daily basis
not just here in the US but around the
world natural resources are a very
important topic I've been working in
this field this area for about 10 years
now and I've even heard people say let's
not use the word natural the phrase
natural resources because nature is more
than just a resource but having said
that just to remind us that those of us
who live in high-income countries are
using many more times to resources than
those who are living in low-income
countries that's the most important
context that I can that I can part with
you today is this issue of accelerating
urbanization so this is a picture that
you see all over the world mostly we
just got back from traveling in Lima in
Bullitt da and if anybody's been to
these capital cities of Latin America
you know what I'm talking about just
incredible density oftentimes very
little nature huge vast slums and this
is often how many of the world's
population is living and to compound
that we're moving as a species we're
moving into urban areas at a really high
rate so by 2050 2/3 of the world's
population will be living in cities that
to thee to me this means that we need to
rethink how we live in cities what is in
our cities how does that affect our
health and what I wanted to point it out
was even the United Nations one of
sustainable goals number 11 to be
specific mentions the importance of
creating green public space green public
space and I don't see that very often
like in literature I don't see a sort of
in the medical literature very often I
don't even see it that often in the
public health world which I also come
from but it's increasingly important as
you can tell as we have this
accelerating urbanization to think about
cities that's where we're going to be
living that's where we're moving to
and how can we incorporate a little more
greenness perhaps into our lives
so this is not the world this is
actually looking at the u.s. this is a
look at chronic disease in the US
according to the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention just to give you
some scope of what we're talking about
here there's a lot going on this is what
I see on a daily basis although I'm a
pediatrician and I thought even though I
thought that I was going into a career
where I would deal with a lot of runny
noses and strep throats and things like
that what I'm dealing mostly with is
that stuff but in the context of
pre-diabetes diabetes high blood
pressure certainly lots and lots of
obesity and a ton of mental health
problems so that's really my life I give
vaccines and all that stuff that we do
as primary care features but I do it in
the context of a lot of chronic disease
so kids we were taught to say that kids
aren't little adults but to be honest
with you kids are looking more and more
like their adult peers and these are
problems that you usually think of in
the adult world there's also an epidemic
of nature deficit and this is very hard
to read for a reason because this is the
amount of time seven minutes four to
seven minutes is the average amount of
time a child spends in unstructured play
outside every day this is the amount of
time seven hours that they spend average
amount of time on some kind of
electronic device or some kind of screen
time now granted it may be doing
homework it's not always you know
playing video games but but this is a
good way to sort of see what's happening
in terms of the way we spend our days
and I didn't point out I don't think I
did this is in four to seven year olds
so you can only imagine what happens as
they grow up
it actually usually intensifies and it
established as a routine a pattern that
they actually did it that they use for
the rest of their life
the same is true with other behaviors we
know that smoking if you start smoking
before the age of 18 you're much much
more likely to smoke the rest of your
life then starting initiation of smoking
after the age of 18 these are the top 10
causes of death also that are I put up
here in part because every one of these
is either directly or indirectly related
to this our lifestyle
right this is a bit exaggerated here but
we sit a lot we don't always eat the
right kinds of food and the right kinds
of ways in the right amount of time we
have a lot of stress and then when you
have all these three things you develop
one of these three things and then you
come to me and you ask for these
generally my life what I see on my end
of things and and which is really true
for most of us who are in the practicing
world
all right enough doom and gloom so this
is the nature pyramid there used to be a
food pyramid which you may or may not
remember which I don't like very much
now we use the plate and we portion it
out I actually really do like the nature
pyramid because it gives you a good idea
and this is from I believe the
University of North Carolina I was kind
of thing but anyway what I want to point
out is on the very bottom of the pyramid
is low frequency a high frequency low
intensity so these are the things like
the gardens the rooftops campus here you
have a lot of greenery here things that
you might actually see every day maybe
even every hours and as you move toward
the top of the pyramid it's much more
intense and less frequent so I just went
to you know hike on the Inca Trail I may
never do that again in my life
right so very very low frequency high
intensity right so it was amazing I saw
that little bomb by River
I saw orchids just peering over a
thousands of feet draw amazing things I
saw which is great wonderful but it's
not what we're going to do every day so
I'm focusing my career in my time down
here I happen to call it the
foundational work because it is the
vision of the pyramid but it is really
important especially as we move into
cities and more so we live in cities we
move into cities because this is what
most people are going to have access to
not travelling to even a state park
which many of my patients I work at a
committee health center so I see
primarily low-income patients in DC
Columbia Heights so even they rarely get
to Rock Creek which is just a mile away
right and they even even rare rare more
rarely gets a Blue Ridge now
for example which is an hour-and-a-half
drive away so having city parks have an
urban areas having Gardens having
greenery around you is even more
important for these populations onto the
evidence so um not everybody here may
know what a systematic review is I think
the majority you probably do but it's
important to have inclusion criteria
often a meta analysis as part of a
systematic review and it's a quick way
for us to take a bunch of data at
different numbers of studies that that
might actually give you an in some
insight into certain questions that need
to be asked so the questions are you
know what happens when we spend time
outdoors I'm gonna go through a series
of studies and you'll see some of the
similarities as I go through this one
certainly is a there's a marker for
stress a biomarker cortisol stress
cortisol there's a decrease in decrease
in heart rate Israel decrease in blood
pressure cholesterol I want to read all
these you can read them yourself heart
rate variability is important and that
is our ability to go up and then back
down again and how quickly you get back
down again so you want actually a high
heart rate very but not a low heart rate
variability when I was a med student and
doing OB we talked about that with the
fetal the fetal rate but actually it's
now used oftentimes to talk about the
effect of nature on on human health
another systematic review focused on 133
controlled studies and the intervention
itself was these adventure based
activities short-term walking seated
relaxation and national environments and
what do they find they found this is
more than a mental health piece but
psychological well-being psychosocial
function psychosis physiological stress
response cognitive performance all these
things improved one thing that's a
little difficult in this literature is
that even though I mentioned there over
500 studies that are published they're
all seemingly quite different in their
methodology and study design so it makes
doing a systematic review kind of hard
it makes coming with these grand
conclusions a little bit hard so I just
want to point that out that this is you
know we're still learning a lot about
nature and human health but learning
about the mechanisms as well there's
another study here done a 2018 I tried
to find the most sort of recent
group of studies that has come out and
you know you see a decrease in mortality
heart rate and violence some of the
earliest studies done by min Kuo
University of Illinois we're actually
looking at a low-income housing that was
built initially had greenery quite a bit
over the years wasn't maintained as some
areas was maintained in others and what
she found was to her not to her surprise
really because she worked with animals
before caged animals and animals living
in natural environments was that the
animals who lived in more natural
environments they lived longer they had
better social interactions and the same
she found was true for humans so where
humans lived in us in this low-income
housing that had some greenery they had
less violence they had better social
interactions so it's not surprising that
your you would live longer if you lived
closer to and therefore had more access
to green space another thing that's been
found which maybe is intuitive to many
people is an increase in physical
activity and it wasn't necessarily
intuitive to me initially but when I
think about it when I'm outside and when
you're outside you are much more likely
to move even if you picnic outside
you're more likely to get up and walk
around throw the frisbee maybe
investigate something you're more likely
to eat slowly actually when you're
outside so there's a there's a
interesting things that we've been able
to find attention and mood I'll get to
in just a second there has been some
research looking at ADHD and I'll
mention that and dr. Koh's work just a
little bit later on
Forest Therapy I wanted to share with
you a little bit I don't know if you
mentioned already but I'll be doing a
walk and it's really for dr. rake house
class and it's going to be a two and a
half hour
force therapy walk so the question is
being out in this forested area or being
out in nature you know what are the
effects you know what actually happens
so once that we did look at that a
relatively small sample size but they
did find some positive impacts of
lowering and high blood pressure some
cardiac and pulmonary function
improvement and you can see the rest of
those things listed here there is strong
evidence that Green is associated with
even more thing so improvements in birth
weight
mentioned physical activity and this is
even some researchers to talk about
policy so we probably should be thinking
about once again you know how to design
how to change cities how to design
cities urban areas so that people all
people have access to these areas I'm
gonna run over here though I'm running
at a time so I'm gonna go a little
faster okay I just want make sure we get
there's a lot of science in here but I
think for the purpose of this lecture
we'll go a little bit faster there's
some individual studies that I found
fastly want to share with you this is a
pretty recent study that in 2018 and it
was done in Spain there were two
different areas where they tracked
children through many years and what
they did was they had two areas one area
had a and they look sort of geospatially
to see how green and not green these two
areas were so one area not very green
one area quite green and to my surprise
they actually did functional MRIs and
they measured the difference in brain
mass and what they found was that the
the kids who grew up in areas where it
was much greener actually had larger
brains that correlated with better
working memory and reduced in
attentiveness there are studies looking
at children and their school settings so
whether a forest school versus a non
forest school and what are the
differences in in cortisol I mentioned
cortisol is a stress hormone so we know
that for school students have a steady
decline in cortisol and we know it's
constant throughout the year and we also
know that the profile of these students
in the indoor class are similar to
individuals prone to stress associated
mental disorders like depression so
there is already some evidence looking
and evaluating the outcomes in these
kinds of of educational settings this is
a study that I actually did there aren't
many studies yet looking at the park
prescription meaning a educator a health
professional would actually write a
prescription and by the way that's
happening has been happening for is it
two years now or more than important at
Cornell two years at Cornell health
and dr. Rekha we'll talk about that in
just a little bit so it's the idea of
actually writing a prescription for a
patient or a client to spend time in
nature and I'll talk more about the way
that I do it and that my nonprofit
actually promotes that this was done in
2013 and what we found was something
very important to me which was this is
sort of before and after so pre and post
intervention invention was the
prescription it was in children and what
we found was that children are
definitely more likely to visit a park
and actually increase their level of
physical activity by virtue of the
prescription there's another study done
by another pediatrician a colleague of
mine at at UCSF dr. rosani and what she
did was the randomized trial and she had
two groups of kids and families one
received the very plain park
prescription which I do and then one
group received the park prescription
plus all the bells and whistles which
means they got transportation provided
for them on Saturdays they went to a
local park
they had a naturalist with them they had
a photographer with them they had food
with them it was a production okay and
they do this every Saturday that's
called shine it's an acronym for the
organization that she would she's
founded and what she looked at was
stress reduction and to her surprise
um the group that got just the the plane
apart prescription with no bells and
whistles did just as well in stress
reduction so you know good for all of us
really not just good for me right
because I but I was reassured that you
don't have to have all those resources
necessarily to make some value out of
this park prescription that there's
something happening there my own
hypothesis is that there's something
special in that relationship between a
client patient and their you know
primary care provider or the
psychologist their educator some trusted
professional in their life and I think
that has a lot to do with this is why
it's actually happening I mentioned dr.
dr. claman quo so dr. Taylor turquo did
a study that's really landmark studies
about attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder once again to actually were
more than two there are three treatment
arms one arm of
these are kids who all have ADHD one
went to a city park and the other two
went to urban settings and what she
found was that the kids who went to a
park and had unstructured play did just
as well in their ADHD symptom all of
symptom all symptomology so there's a
checklist of symptoms for ADHD as kids
who've had a dose of methylphenidate
which is a stimulant at four hours out
which is the maximal effect usually on a
short-acting stimulant medication as the
kids who who went on a walk in and just
I'm sorry played in a natural setting
this is not to say that you know if
anybody in here as ADHD should stop your
meds right away and go out to the
Botanic Gardens but it is a little bit
of food for thought to think about your
you know could nature actually be a
treatment option for many kids and and I
think the answer is from my own practice
that it's certainly an adjunct so when I
have kids who come in with attention
problems one of the first things I do is
we talk about diet or routine and
certainly clay when where do they play
goo they play outside things like that
and what I find even in the very very
low-income populations is that they just
don't have that kind of unstructured
time very similar to kids of high income
I mentioned forest bathing so shinrin
yoku is the japanese term for forest
bathing and there is a another realm of
research done in Japan how am i doing on
time good
and so dr. Lee did this research this
was pretty landmark research looking at
not just at natural killer cells but
that's what's talked about a lot and
natural killer cells are an important
part of our immune system they're a more
ancient part of our immune system and
thoughts really protect us against
cancer so they float around our blood
and they look for abnormality to look
for cells that are reproducing too fast
hence you know cells that might be
heading towards the cancer and they and
they take care of that problem so having
a natural killer cells is a good thing
having activity natural killer cell
activity is a good thing better thing
for you so one thing that has been
established is that the fighting sides
these essential oils
and I'm not a botanist I'm not a
horticulturalist but from what I
understand yell out if I'm saying
something completely off the mark here
but I think it's Cypress and pine are
two of these books
okay so Pines oak and okay and Oaks and
Cypress Cypress to give you an example
have these natural occurring chemicals
that do seem to increase our level of
natural killer cells and among other
things I mentioned in here as well I
don't want to go there there's other
chemical meteors but I put him in if you
wanted to see I thought what was most
fascinating with this is that if you
look over here so this is these are
these are 2 9 three-day excursions going
into a forested area in Japan and what
happens you know when you take blood
samples and you measure natural killer
cells on day on before day 1 to 7 and 30
and what what they found was that it's
it rises it elevates but it stays
elevated it stays elevated 30 days out
and when you compare that to an urban
setting you don't see any significant
change so one of the things that one of
the points that they suggested and in
this research is you know frequency
right so how often should we go into a
forested area how often should we do
this these kinds of outings he's
suggesting and the team is suggesting
that maybe at least once a month which i
think is pretty phenomenal that there's
there's even a frequency and perhaps a
dose related to this so I've gone
through quite a bit of the research I
hope I've left you with something
perhaps you haven't seen before there
are many places obviously this crowd
knows where to go to find scientific
studies but you may not have heard of
the children and Nature Network research
library and if you haven't heard of it
it's a good place and it's not just
about children it actually spans all
ages and it's a nice compilation of the
research that's been done on nature and
health in one place so I go to PubMed
too but it's a nice really easy place to
find a lot of what I've just gone
through with you so what does this mean
for me what does this mean for all my
colleagues around the world frankly and
when I heard richelieu speak when I read
his book last child in the woods and
since then
many other books nature fixes another
one I've read by Florence Williams you
know I'm a doctor I'm a plumber I'm a
technician I'm not you know I've been a
researcher so intensely involved as many
of you have been or will be but I'm
practical I want to know what I can do
with this I want to know where do we
apply this as do you so but when I go
back to the office I don't know how can
I put this information into practice so
I'm gonna give you some idea of what I
have done and what others have done so
there's there's four programs that come
to mind track trails walk with the Doc
Association of nature and forest therapy
and park corrects America I mentioned
forest bathing or shinrin yoku which is
an ancient Japanese tradition nothing
really new about that but the
association of nature and forest therapy
has taken the concept of nature nature
of a forest bathing and really gone in
in a slightly different direction so
it's called nature therapy and the idea
is for a guide to really open the doors
so to speak to a therapy that is
experienced if I'm by virtue of being in
nature to put it simply I'm talking a
little bit from from a scientific
perspective but I'm also talking from a
personal one because I'm right now a
guide I'm a guide in training for this
association nature force therapy so I
went through an eight day course and I'm
in my sixth month practicum right now
and I'm actually leading a walk a two
and a half walk our walk today
there's a standard set of principles and
values for all of us who are guides
there are over 600 guides this might be
a little outdated it's on their website
and I was trying to get you a more
recent number I've in communication with
the with the two directors I think it's
closer to a thousand guys right now
around the world a majority of them are
going to be in the US Europe Australia
those countries but they are in
sprinting around around the world and
the idea really is that when you are
taking this science because there's a
lot of science now you know what do you
do with it and the role of the guide is
to you know create a safe place to use a
standard sequence
so it's not random what we do in that
sense and we start off with something
that we call we've got we do these
things called invitation so we invite
you to open your senses and wherever
that nature you know that place might be
and it really engage your senses and by
virtue of doing that
clearly there are physical outcomes that
come from that there are mental health
outcomes that come from that but in
addition to that in my own personal
experience there's also this relational
thing that happens so you start to from
a relationship with nature which i think
is also probably part of what's
happening in terms of our getting better
there's a concept in na na and ft an
association Asian force therapy called
medicine and it's not the medicine that
I was taught necessarily but medicine
for us we defined medicine is not my
curing you but rather a reciprocal
relationship so if I'm if I'm relating
to a tree or I'm relating to of fauna
there's they're also relating back to me
so oh a phrase that's often used is the
more than human world what's out there
and how do we relate to it a little
woowoo for some people when you first
hear about it it's ok I was one of my
edges when I first started like I don't
know I'm a doctor I don't like to do
this you know I write prescriptions but
I've really taken to it and I think
there's a lot of value in this and just
even being in the Botanic Gardens today
being walking alone gorges going to a
state park yesterday just being here on
this campus there's a lot that could
happen I think here on the campus that
might be done through this means pretty
amazing stuff that happens through this
association David I know all the
founders yep of all these really so
going back that Amos Clifford is the
person who started this David Sanger is
a cardiologist based in Ohio he started
an organization that's now international
called walk with a doc this is probably
a little more out in the you know
popular culture anybody heard of walk
with the dog huh that's not yet okay
very simple idea right so yeah walk with
a doc it doesn't get too much deeper
than that
so David got frustrated
many years ago about you know patients
not doing so well there's a branch of
Cardiology called preventive cardiology
he doesn't just do that but you know if
I have a patient who's morbidly obese
and whatever is not working I sometimes
will refer to a preventive cardiologist
to see what can be done on their end as
well
so he suggested on some Saturday listen
and to all I don't know how he did this
but he must have sent out a
communication to all his patients I'm
gonna be at this park on Saturday if you
want to join me a gentleman I'm going
for a walk a hundred of his patients
showed up there is a first there's an
appetite for this much more than we
think and to walk with your doctor is
pretty cool because usually have to go
there office you have to pay insurance
and whatnot so a really neat idea it's
taken taken taken root and often I've
I've been on these walks before myself
they're great walks and usually as a
brief presentation before the walk and
it's usually done you know outdoors but
it can't be done indoors and questions
and and and the conversation happens as
you walk and the one I went on was Poe
about an hour and a half or so we did it
at the u.s. Arboretum there's over 500
chapters worldwide and you can see here
how fast it's growing from 14 to 18 the
number of walks and then the walker
visits per year so it is working I don't
have all of their data and but I
encourage you to visit the website and
learn more about them there is Cornell
health here there's a city here so I
mean there are doctors here doesn't have
to be a doctor now it's really been
there are nurse practitioners or other
types of specialists who are and gotten
and health practitioners who are doing
this as well
Jason euros runs walk sorry walk runs
track trails kids and parks and also a
very very wonderful program the idea
here is that this was really started
primarily focused on children although
now I understand it's also fitting
adults but the idea is that we can get
if we can get people out to trails and
the initially partnered with
pediatricians offices it started and in
North Carolina they had some funding
from the Blue Ridge Parkway Foundation
the National Park Service and Blue Cross
Blue Shield
and the idea was to connect people with
these trails by virtue of the
pediatricians offices so they would put
up the the information about what can
happen how you can get connected to
these trails on the trails they're
keeping you engaged so they have
activities you can do actually on the
trails from biking hiking geocaching
paddling I remember way back they were
doing the disc golf as well so it's
keeping folks engaged there's also sort
of this treasure hunt sort of a thing so
when you're going I've gone on these
myself as well we have several in the DC
area and what they do is they partner
with Parks Park agencies national parks
state parks and municipal parks who
already have the trails so they're not
building trails they're partnering with
those agencies and they'll put up some
of the signage and allow the activities
to happen on those trails and they're
tracking the steps and the numbers of
times these kids are actually doing this
so they have fantastic data that this
actually works the last one is is my
organization Parker X America we started
out in DC we call we called ourselves DC
Parker X we had initially 20 parts
around the health center where I work
that were in a platform for us to
prescribe we now have over 7,000 parks
in our in our platform we are not a
program parker x america is really a
platform meaning that you could take
this idea of prescribing to any place in
the world where you would find some
accessible green space some burden of
chronic disease and a willingness to
prescribe those really the three
important ingredients we are a
non-profit the main goal our main
mission really is to educate educate
educate health professionals provide
them with a tool a platform for them to
actually prescribe to their patients
it's free so we don't charge anything
for it and the prescription itself is
something that I've struggled with for
years you think how would I swat what I
struggle with a prescription I'm a
doctor but what I mean by that is the
park prescription now clearly you know
if I were to prescribe an antibiotic or
some medication to you I wouldn't say to
you dr. ray cow take any antibiotic you
like for us
often as you like whatever dose you like
with with or without food and I'll see
you back whenever great it's a 10-day
course it's twice a day it's 500
milligrams or it's a liquid for child
it's palatable you know you with food
avoid the Sun you give somebody some
specific instructions that makes up the
prescription so I really ran with this
and I said you know what let's just do
this for the park prescription because I
was finding that all these incredible
program these parkour programs around
the country were kind of loosey-goosey
about the prescription and I wanted to I
don't think that's gonna work and so
what I wanted to do a trial on was let's
make it specific so the park
prescription that we do on our platform
is very specific it has to have a park
or place right it has to have an
activity now the activity could be you
can imagine a lot of different things
right
it could be stargazing it could be
forest bathing it could be playing
tennis we're taking your dog for a walk
you know things that your patients tell
you about what they want to do what they
like to do the place is important
because I want them to tell me where
they feel comfortable where they feel
safe where as close to them so those are
the first two the second two things are
the frequency and the duration I need to
know how long they're willing to commit
to this activity when they do it and how
many times per week bingo now I've got
it my time is almost up or it's up so
this is how I define the park
prescription it's not how the world
defines it I would like the world to
define it this way but we're not there
yet so I'm really pushing for this I
think it's important to standardize and
harmonize who we can research and
evaluate and study and make it
clinically effective for all of us to do
it the same way within those parameters
it's electronic so I send my patient a
text or an email they get it and they
respond every time they go so when I see
them at the follow-up visit I know how
many times they filled the prescription
I don't know that about antibiotics I do
know that about the Parc prescription so
when I walk in I have knowledge and I'm
holding them to that contract as well we
have over 500 per scribers around the
world mostly in the u.s. right now we've
made a lot of prescriptions and we've
had a lot filled don't be discouraged
what's happening I have found there's a
lot of these 500-plus
are doing it their way and I'm
encouraging them to do it our way
so it's more clinically relevant to them
to their patients more effective and so
I can have the data with that I'm going
to pass it on to dr. ray Cao thank you
so much well thank you doctors are for
sharing so much meaningful and really
inspiring information with us what I'd
like to do is build from the remarks
that doctors are shared with us and talk
about a specific program that we have
here at Cornell called nature rx at
Cornell so many of you are graduate
students some of you are undergraduate
students and the first thing I'd like to
share is that college should be a time
of learning for exploration for
developing new skills and for fun
College should be fun but for so many
students college and university life is
filled with mental and physical and
performance related problems you know
the latest 2018 National Collegiate
health assessment just came out they
survey nearly 28,000 students on 44
campuses and here are some of the
findings from that large assessment in
the previous 12 months 20% of students
felt that things were hopeless 20% of
students felt very lonely 17% of
students felt so depressed that it was
difficult to function and 18% felt
overwhelming anxiety or overwhelming
anger and nearly 7% indicated that they
had considered suicide these are
staggering and
very disturbing statistics so based on
all the doctors are just shared with
with us we know that there is a body of
scientific evidence that clearly
indicates that spending time in nature
is beneficial to us physically
physiologically behaviorally so our
challenge is how do we convince students
here at Cornell and at other campuses to
actually spend intentional time out in
nature and the reason I include that
word intentional is that I've done some
very unscientific preliminary
investigating by standing on one end of
the trip hammer bridge and watched
students crossing over that bridge in
the morning on their way to class and
90% of them are looking at their iPhones
they're not aware of the fact that this
spectacularly beautiful Beebe Lake and
trip hammer Falls are right there so to
me those are unintentional experiences
in nature so a number of years ago
several colleagues and I David cutter
being one of them
were on a coffee break during some
Cornell conference and we started to
think about the fact that Cornell has
truly one of the most beautiful campuses
in America but that we also have one of
the highest percentages in our student
body of students suffering from mental
health problems so we thought couldn't
there be some way of better utilizing
all of that natural beauty and
horticultural beauty as a way of
contributing to the well-being of our
students and that really was the genesis
of nature rx at Cornell so there are
five
components of nature Rx and i'd like to
speak about each of these individually a
nature prescription program a nature rx
website nature rx class that doctors are
and I are about to go off to a nature
Ipoh stirring and finally a student
nature rx Club and I'm glad to see we
have some of the officers of the club
here
so first the nature prescriptions as
doctors are mentioned this program
started at Cornell Health a couple of
years ago and at that time we were
working with a relatively small number
of health professionals at Cornell
health but we had convinced these health
professionals to hand out a paper
prescription as part of the therapy or
treatment recommended for students who
were suffering from depression anxiety
high levels of stress obesity
self-cutting suicidal ideation any of
those complexes and it said take a walk
or run around Beebe Lake rest on the
slope enjoy a sunset and spend twenty
minutes two to three times a week
well some students actually paid
attention to this we think that many
students did not so in this previous
academic year we actually were able to
integrate the nature prescription into
the electronic health record and it's
very hard for you to see from there but
you can see it says nature rx discussed
and recommended so now in this previous
academic year over 700 students were
recommended time in nature by more than
two dozen health professionals at
now health before I move on to that a
new development that is about to start
which we are particularly excited about
is that this year Cornell Health has
developed a method to confidentially an
anonymously survey all of the students
getting prescribed nature so that we'll
be able to assess things like did they
in fact follow the prescription how
frequently are they going out in nature
where are they going out in nature is it
reducing their stress level so we'll
have an actual body of information about
Cornell students being prescribed nature
another component of the program is our
nature rx website on nature Rx cornell
dot edu don't look it up right now
listen to me but do look it up right
after the seminar so the idea behind the
website is we wanted students we do want
students to get over the mindset of oh
yeah you know I've heard nature is good
for me but I don't have an hour to
devote for that I have to get to class I
have to go to lab I have to write papers
so through this website we profile 15
natural and landscape sites around
campus many of them managed by Cornell
Botanic Gardens and we provide GPS based
walking directions on how to get from
wherever you are right now to the
nearest Nature rx site typically five
minutes or less of walking time to get
to that site so you don't have an hour
that's fine
take 15 minutes to walk to this site
and a little time there and then walk to
your next assignment a third element is
our nature rx class we piloted this
class last fall and based on the success
of it we have now made it a regular part
of the curriculum PL sei 1125 it's also
part of engaged learning where you live
at Cornell so its intended to appeal
particularly to first-year students at
North Campus and second year students
and we're very grateful that engaged
Cornell is providing funding for the
class so we have 18 students enrolled in
the course this fall and as doctors are
just explained we're about to or he is
about to take them on a to our nature
therapy experience and walk so in the
class last year as part of the
curriculum I asked the students to
develop a relationship with a spot on
campus in which they would feel
particularly safe and calm and I had
them write critical reflections about
their special spot but one week I said
your assignment for next week is to
develop a non written reflection on your
spot of peace and calm so some students
did art pieces that were reflections of
their special spot one student who what
is a freshman so was here for the very
first time had come from South Florida
and had never experienced autumn before
so she played the full component of the
Valdez four seasons as her way
of showing her appreciation for
experiencing fall a fourth component of
nature rx at Cornell we don't want just
the students who are experiencing mental
health problems and going to Cornell
health to know about and take advantage
of nature rx and just the students who
are enrolled in our nature rx class we
want all students to be aware of this so
working with the communications team at
Cornell Health we have developed this
series of Ipoh stirrers you may have
seen them in the foyer of the plant
science building and they say such
things as did you know that time spent
in nature can improve your exam scores
improve your social life improve your
sleep patterns and reduce overall stress
levels and for each of these we cite
papers that have verified that benefit
finally we have a nature rx Club made up
of both undergraduate students and grad
students and the club is just forming
for this academic year and they are
planning a series of walks in nature
experiences in nature presentations by
people related to this field and
hopefully that nature rx Club is going
to expand and engage more and more
students also I recently wrote and or
co-authored and published a book with
dr. Gregory eels who until recently was
the director of our counseling and and
psychiatric services division of Cornell
health
it is called nature rx improving college
student mental health and in that book
we provide an overview of the kinds of
mental health challenges students are
facing today we also provide a stepwise
process for developing a nature rx
program on your campus and we talk about
the role of nature rx programs in the
context of the future of the American
University the final thing I'll mention
is that the nature rx program here at
Cornell is just one of several nature rx
programs on American campuses in our
book we profiled the programs at Cornell
but also at three other campuses UC
Davis University of Minnesota and
College of William & Mary from that core
of four colleges and universities we
have just this year
developed a nature rx campus network and
the network members are all over the US
and just starting to be in Canada also
and its large universities small
universities colleges geographically
diverse and as the coordinator of the
campus on nature rx network I send a
weekly e-newsletter to the members in
which the best practices at individual
campuses are described opportunities for
collaboration are brought out a recent
literature that is pertinent to our
field is cited and a subgroup of
network members are now working on
developing a virtual symposium for
campuses for next spring in which we're
hoping to involve a hundred or more
campuses around North America so there's
no doubt that we live in a very tense
and stress filled world we live in a
world with unfortunate but tremendous
examples of environmental degradation
but we also live in a world where there
are programs like Park rx America like
our campus nature rx movement that
really gives us hope for the future
because they recognize the human
benefits of time in nature and they
provide mechanisms for people to spend
that time so thank you very much on
behalf of doctors our and myself and I
would like to say that we have time for
questions I think we can take maybe two
and then we actually have to go off to
the nature rx class so if there are a
couple of questions David talks and
programs and I particularly like the
father-son matching shirt getting access
to green spaces in different
environments is to create smallish
horticultural gardens as anybody looked
at the difference between visiting a
small horticultural garden versus
getting out and I in our bigger nature
place with big trees I can address that
so there have been a number of studies
that have looked at the human health
benefits of spending
time in a botanical garden those studies
have not quantified size of garden and
related that to impact but one study
that looked at four different botanic
gardens in Florida found that the
experience of walking through the garden
was particularly impactful for that
cohort that had self-identified before
the visit as having very high stress
levels so we know that spending time in
a botanic garden can reduce stress and
cortisol levels and blood pressure so it
does not I'm fond of saying it doesn't
have to involve the forest primeval one
more question anyone yes Ken the most of
the experiment most of the studies you
cited or fairly structured and long in
prescription but what about a more
natural experiment for example if as as
you know opportunity state parks or jism
if you if you take a large random sample
there are eight people you know not
doing it destructively but - I see -
those people yeah so just a quick thank
you for the question and the question is
you know in terms of the studies that I
was going through and just to be maybe I
was I'm just a quickly you know
clarification on the vast majority of
the research is actually not on the park
prescription the vast majority of the
research it has to do with the things
that you just mentioned is just people
being in green space living near green
space having access to green space group
outings things of that nature
the and the literature is is pretty
convincing that being in the in or near
these green areas has a substantial
health effect and I went through a lot
of those with
with all of you in fact the opposite is
true with the studies that we have a
paucity of studies that are more
clinically focused and and on that note
you know I I'll be partnering I am
partner actually now already with RAND
Corporation Deb Cowan and we're going to
be doing a randomized trial funded by
the NIH it's a five-year trial and we're
going to look at the more clinical side
of things we're going to be looking at
the accelerometry so you know whether
it's moderate to vigorous physical
activity as a result of prescription
we're gonna be looking at some diabetes
measures cholesterol triglycerides and
ADHD so we're going to be looking at
those but there as I mentioned earlier
there's really just a handful of studies
that are clinical studies but you know
despite having so few clinical studies
I'm very convinced with the science that
being in nature has measurable and many
positive effects on human health so I
would love to have a stay and answer
further questions but class time beckons
for us and probably for many of you so
thank you for your attention this
afternoon and we will see you again next
Monday this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu